[Music]
you imagine if you could ever capture
life in a
film I would like to introduce Daniel
hello here's a little boy Dan had these
Visions about this film he was going to
make all I do is I have a video camera
in my hand and I believe that life is an
interesting enough story not with my
open closet Dan don't videotape me right
now over the years Dan traveled to 42
countries he was genuinely curious about
people I feel like I'm manifesting the
plot line of my dreams what's the
biggest thing that we don't understand
don't cut cat no it's nature and the
universe Daniel collected something from
everywhere that he went to remain
connected to that place this is my
favorite one so far these bones were
charged with bad
vibes I don't think you should take
anything you feel the shift of reality
run Felix run
no I've been making that documentary for
a years this is an unexpected
turn we've had to look under the
microscope and this is acute
leukemia tell
me where are you going I remember Dan
saying it's linked to my
film put yourself in the position of the
character they tell you there's 6 months
to live I don't want to find out what
happens next I want to stay
here I'm trying to figure out how to
write a twist
ending together get us close as you
can okay here we go when you were my age
nothing will be the same make a wish
nobody knows what I'm wishing
for you will find the reason for
yourself Bri it will shine in your life
as brightly as the sun shines in the
sky and most
importantly remember that life is
beautiful even when it is sad or scary
look for that
beauty that made the whole trip worth
[Music]
it